good evening everybody thank you for
coming out this evening I shall begin by
reading out the emergency evacuation
announcement should we be responsive
actually would you please leave the
building by the nearest 10 minutes
there is one fire exit in this room if
you need to evacuate room do so by the
buttocks towards the external quiet
escape staircase
please hold phone cameras and posted
stairs or wet for slippery anyone is
unable to use the stairs but they please
about others to exit the room before
they go to the for escape door where
they can feel assistance
I was simply pointing me in the public
car park at the side of the Civic Suites
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings please do not
return to the building until given
permission to do so by council staff
please note that this meeting will be
audio recorded and kenora by members and
all within deeds to turn on mobile
phones are switched to silent please
thank you very much
jinda item number one which is for
absent but we have apologies for my
counselor mrs. Shaw counselor mrs.
Gooding and counselor mr. Roy substitute
members we have counselor mrs. Weston
for counselor mr. Shaw and counselor F
deep floor counsel mrs. Gooding and
counselor mrs. Roy for counselor mr.
Boyd no members attending counselor
water and counselor Williams December 25
received declarations of interest
including any between declarations
[Music]
I just want just say that just in case
it needs to be serviced thank you very
much agenda item number 6 which is the
operation of the development committee
for this item
we broke the Marcos problem persistent
director environmental services and
counselor mr. holder for planning this
subject
highlight any members do we need to be
aware of and answer your questions at
the end it's got a quality decision
making which is a bit of a tricky thing
from these fruits it's a sort of
colophon good it's subjective in its
nature so I think you know that that was
well I guess I was struggling this so we
looked at so the appeal to see
the fields have changed considerably
between post and pre there's a change in
the size of committee this even perhaps
they're big the number of pills
increased or if the number of pills have
increased and they were found to be
wanting by these sort of we're going to
go into some scrutiny that sort of thing
you know it in all honesty I think the
number of pills that have occurred for
an hour for such a small number I think
as I've said really it's very hard to
say that there's any empirical evidence
one way or the other so yes it's made
any difference so you know and and there
could be a number of reasons why anyway
so even there wasn't trend here we have
to say is that trend is jusu besides the
committee it could be a number of
factors so you know in many ways well I
think went to the Connor what is a
typical committee size for for Asics
authorities and to conclude that it's
broader than the rhyming job of those of
cross Essex saying that you know there
is no conclusions such but I think it is
a very short report in that matter but
it's very hard to make a quality of
judgment on what is a good and bad
decision and so I've steered away from
if you wish in many ways I'm just trying
to keep to what I see the set of data
taking questions on there okay thank you
very much
no one's even catered at the moment and
just a very quick question
just afraid of a question have there
actually been any specific complaints
from members or the public since the
2015 move regarding the composition of
the committee I mean I haven't looked
them specifically so I'm not aware of
any complaints as such or there was some
concerns Ryan's line I believe you came
to this committee but I'm not aware any
to the public complaints of such a you
know the committee Thank You mr.
chairman I agree with what you say me
because it is a very subjective subject
and your report as you say you can't
draw any conclusion but your report only
covers one aspect which is the
statistical aspect well it hasn't
covered is what the previous planning or
Development Committee used to be
learning how it operated and the
benefits that are quoted from that and
and some of the members here won't have
been on a full planning committee so I
will explain when you have the full 39
members or 30 or it's not everyone's
hands up it doesn't matter you will find
that the meetings tend to take a bit
longer because more people speak but at
the same time as members speak and you
have a breadth of information and a
breadth of knowledge and a breadth of
experience there you'll find that it's
actually for less experienced members is
more valuable if there's a training
ground then at any training session can
be especially as it's normally every
month so from that point of view the
less experienced members and I was one
once you sit there and you learn and
then you say something and you're
probably long but your peers will
correct you and you will learn and you
will become very experienced by that
process so I think that's one thing we
have lost because with the smaller
number of members we don't have that the
other
experience that we're not getting is the
impact of local knowledge before with
with a full committee what would what we
would have would be you would have
always that nearly always have all
counselors there and you would have
people have been on the site visit
because there are so many members some
would have invariably have been and you
would have people with very extensive
knowledge none of that has been covered
in your report there's not a criticism
because I realize it's very difficult to
do so without that that sort of
knowledge but it isn't reflected in
there the so that there's the training
it element the experience of various
members which hasn't been covered
there's also to my point of view and
this again is subjective is that it's
more democratic because you've got more
points of view it's more democratic and
my experience of the two committees has
been that that the smaller committee
seems to be dominated by officer opinion
much more than member opinion and in my
view I think the members are there to
represent the community so I think it
does feel slightly on on that ground
just as you say he's subjective and I
think that we should be looking at those
points examining them and seeing you
know where the balance of those points
about it rather than just a narrow
statistical area that we have there so
have you considered it you should be
because it is subjective in a report if
you've got in many ways the opinions of
the members say named which be unusual
things have written in a report so not
interviews the members on their views
almost remember the experience of this
and views of this I guess is where you
bring this to the Dewback rather than
within the report because I
you know it like to be it's it becomes a
viewpoint then doesn't it so tonight I'm
going to people isn't valued babe you've
really helped me to capture I think
conflicting views of members within can
I see there so yes that's something that
perhaps would help and yeah from a
personal point of view have served on
both I would no longer serve I find it
I'm Democratic and unpleasant and that's
nothing personal about the people only
had nothing personal in the chairing the
structure is such now is that all I'm
gonna ask to do is to rubber-stamp the
offices before no point there is no
point from my perspective but it was
before we would have so many points of
view and you understand it now it seems
to be they're almost diametrically
opposed sometimes and and I don't think
it's constructive but that is personal
but the training it showed that the
training that that provided for members
was available and we have lost that
Thank You chairman things that I've
noticed because I've had the experience
of being in both environments and it
seems to be a point that's been raised
by a number of counselors is is that we
have committee members and there's also
members who come to the meeting they may
be
or got particular interest in our
applications that's there and I have the
opportunity to speak but they're
disadvantaged in the way that the
current system is set up in respect that
if they want to ask questions of offices
they may get a response but they may not
because they're only allowed to speak
for a set period of time and only once
they're not able to come back on any
answers that they receive because they
may not have get got the clarification
or or the information back from the
offices that they were specifically
looking for and it's then left to the
committee members to pick up on this if
they don't but they might miss that and
therefore some of the information or
some of the experience of the ward
councillor may be missing in part of the
debate so I would if there was going to
be an adjustment to it I would think
that one of the things that could be
done it's helped with the debate and and
to gain the some of the local knowledge
which counsel Mason was was what was
kinks in it in what she was saying was
there to be some flexibility and allow
if questions are asked by guest members
that they have the opportunity to come
back and the follow-up if they or if
they don't receive the clarification or
information that this they originally
looking for when they when they were we
can look at how because he's operating
in terms of representation as well you
know cemented my I guess my base line as
well it works the most across the county
you know and I think you're also reduce
the size wealth increase assignment
comes from we're not saying it's crap
saying that come with you then that's
not to say that every planning committee
operates in some way as ours does in
terms of how presentations not listened
to so I'm happy to go back to look to
see whether you know room for manoeuvre
there I understand that if you wish to
come back there isn't there is no one
way isn't it you stand up you say you
pay something in to sit down capsule of
Westerners just asked to comment
directly on that understand what you're
saying councillor Mason I'm on the
Development Committee and the person who
is not a member of the committee
speaks they all will have to come back
and it has happened on a few occasions
I'm a councillor Hoyer's when he was
there he has asked a few questions and
obviously it's up to the Chairman easily
if if he allows it that's another aspect
I was quite also understanding is if
anybody's interested in in development
then they can go to the training courses
think that they can sell as much as they
like they can come to it they can come
to their committees they can talk in the
committees they can be there for their
residents we're not sort of saying that
because they only got a few members on
the committee that other members can't
come and talk on a sticky subject an
issue is that in their area anybody can
do that
so all that I'm understand what you're
saying which counts mr. Mason I do
believe that you know
every counselor is allowed to come and
speak on any issue at all but again it's
up to the Chairman if he allows the the
person on the committee to talk to all
the ones anything it has has happened if
I could come back from that because
there's a slight confusion there I
didn't raise the point that was
counselor who either raised the point
about not being announced it speaking I
must admit I've not never been there
where someone's been allowed to speak a
second time I'm not saying it hasn't
happened because I haven't been there
enough but your point that people are
allowed to come to other committee
meetings I've sent they're allowed to
come to this committee there's no one
here and this sort is a member of a
committee bye-bye they don't tend to go
and this is a very very special reason
occasionally we'll get one member here I
think we may have an occasion had two
other committees we never get visiting
members it doesn't happen so that
breadth and depth of knowledge is lost
it may the obligation of attending a
meeting means that you do attend when
you can and you do absorb that
information so I suppose our SEP your
point I don't think it's borne out in
practice it's up to member members not
interested in the committee even if
they're not on it maybe they'll are on
it I should say
sometimes you'll find that they won't
they both intend to come up with in my
head just once so don't believe it's up
to the members themselves if they are
really really interested in that
particular committee or subject
I attend the training and compete in the
members time is valuable are they going
to sit there when they don't have to
speak what about Capote okay I can just
ask because counselor Griffin is Austin
to raise a question as well so if you'd
like to ask him questions okay Thank You
chairman um Marcus when the number of 13
councillors was selected to form the new
committee what's up with the intention
of having one counselor from each Ward
that was my understanding yes yes sorry
its programs risen as what I say the
thinking is reduced down to the our
needs to lay on wolves representation as
well so that means if you wish to
object--
if you wish as almost as representing
your residence you are and up hamstrung
quite the same way as if you're part of
the committee so I want subject I'm
going to represent my my reward and I'm
sort of making representations against
this in that sense it's far easy to do
so if you're not on the committee
because you're in danger of
predetermination so you know you have a
freer hand if you like to say exactly
what you think of that application
before it doesn't seem to be formalized
set in stone that if you like would it
help it nobody hung out here more than
them because I'm less familiar with the
history of this than possibly
Johnnie's so I look to you know there's
no requirement or restriction around
Ward's but in terms of size there was
commentary at the time that you know
there's does that many awards perhaps
yeah but there's not actually a connect
and it is pro-rata and equally I thought
given to the size of the other
committees at the time but that's all
thank you thank you my person thank you
fearsome I don't think you chairman them
actually part of what I want you to him
say he's already been said if I if I was
a new councilman want to learn about
development trust me on significant
simple want alleged learn about him I
was part of the committee before when it
was all members and to be honest I'm now
looking forward to rest being able to
represent my ward without being shackled
as to being seen being predetermined and
can I just check there is as far as I'm
a winner and I'm sure it says it in this
paper and I was just looking for there
is no committee that has the old version
we used to have of every single
extensive search of country was
restricted to this County but I think
it's unusual games like thank you and I
think that that was already looked into
before this was proposed and looking at
percentage-wise we've got a percentage
compared to a lot of other local
authorities within their states and
third of 33 percent
that was just my comments really on the
river
Thank You councillor Stanley thank you
just one thing that has come to light
really is that the the expertise on
those on that committee is very sort of
iffy
in as much as some of the simple things
that have been asked or quite sort of
haven't been looked at through the
documentation and I don't know whether
there is a foot of the members on that
committee that haven't looked through
that documentation before that was taken
to committee or whether it's the fault
of the officer and I don't think that
there is sufficient representation from
when they cannot put it when that item
comes to committee
it should be for the wall councillor or
counselors to to put the view forward
because they know the wall more than the
other side of only does if you get my
drift
so is there any way and I don't know but
is there any way that I scheme or I sort
of if you like a committee that can be
presented to to give that view of that
walled in as much as you've got say what
happens over ace wood is really not in
my jurisdiction I would think the wall
councillor in Eastwood would know more
about the world than what I do like I
know more about the world where I am and
he wouldn't know as much so I just
wonder if there's some sort of scheme or
some sort of design that we could just
so are you saying that you almost want
to see you more counselors being
requested is that is that possible I
understood to be to you so you're saying
you still you're planning a committee
make the decision that you've taken on
material presentation the wall members
present their views and practical
experience of that yes good there could
be more dead to
he'll give a bit more insight into
what's happening on landing on their
feet
I'm not saying yes I'm happy to look at
to see the practicality for that always
welcome to contact offices so I think I
think I'll be doing in any of our
counselors in justice to say they're not
interested in their own walls and if
anybody sees anything of the slightest
concern within their ward I'm pretty
sure they make a point of either calling
it in reviewing it being they're putting
their their case on behalf of their
residents so to have a sort of a
selection of I if I see some of you my
ward I'm not happy about or I think
there's concern or I would have put my
case I will be there and I will do what
I do and I'm saying you're the same
block and as long as every other counts
there it is so I think that that
situation is already available to
counselors it
excuse me and they were already fully
implement that if they don't if they
don't that's the fault of the council
themselves because the they have every
opportunity to do it can I just come
back on that and it's how much okay so
when that person when that one counselor
comes back when the from counselor does
bring these that advice or that
information to the committee how much is
that taken in by the committee and is
because the committee are the only ones
that are voting on it they can have that
they've got no idea what's going on the
other side of fabric or wherever
whatever the case might be
but there's only the committee that's
actually having the boat so what I'm
saying is that if you've got people that
do know the area lock yourself and other
other warm counsellors your invaluable
information should be there at the CIM
the committee in the committee to vote
on that particular flavor item E's I
think you should be there to follow
anything it's a broad brush approach
look for this summarize into three main
approaches the obvious is actually
inside Clinton you should remove the dog
fouling in for some lines and some
penalizing the dog fouling all on hkg to
encourage people not to do so in the
first place each has their pros and cons
of the cleansing activity it's just I
guess a reactive approach where their
spokesperson spoons very much onto the
authority to do the cleansing
I experienced as complaints at times you
know why don't you clean this up a wife
cleaned it up and then time wise the
residence for that was happening
birthplace enforcement again I think
I've touched on an area you'll see it's
hard to I think have effective
enforcement that's cost effective so you
know I think that's one of things that
comes across but a great deal of the dog
family enforcement he's done it as an
aside to Albert in for some issues but
it but nevertheless the resource it
takes to I think if you know I penalty
charge for a dog fouling what the
resource is quite intensive so something
to consider I think you know care
the last education which again seems
suggests slightly better outcomes but
again there's require result for
something I think I've been over there
these through the report them it's not
something we have a great deal of as an
authority at this stage it's not so we
could in the future but I think you've
got a suite of options there that you
could use it's really for members of so
perhaps you know actually we interest in
doing a little bit further or not so you
know sort of living very open thank you
very much
Thank You chairman four point eight it's
a little bit disappointing see like only
been one fixed penalty notices and just
a suggestion how to look at a few alpha
and councils online reporting services
some of them offer the ability for
people to have agreed to be a witness
bone in mine
I'm sorry people do tend to pull photos
that they've taken on their CCTV video
somebody's on Facebook thin
be quite willing to be witnesses yes and
I know Mulder news that victory makes
you probably know and actually say we've
got witness statement page of explain
what you noticed and I had some of my
plaintiff said returned
yes that was one offense five point
eight because I mean there's something
we haven't done here I'm suggesting it's
something we certainly could do I mean
you know the the separation of don't
found found from sort of general it was
I think put in place because as an
anticipation at some point legislation
was gonna be brought in to say this is
hazardous it's what we treated
separately it never came in so you know
there isn't a need to actually separate
dr. mouth basically from you general
rubbish so you absolutely it's something
we said we perhaps we could do we I
suspect do very simply and just just
excited sticky welcome to play you'll
see those another other sites and lastly
on five point seven you probably know
where you will know a lot of parishes
ask for dog feelings yes I know there's
initial cost and then there's revenue
cause have we actually put this out to
parishes to say should you want another
one this is the criteria that we've got
to be able to get to them to be able to
influence it we've been ongoing console
we can put absolutely a criterion price
together I don't see what I thank you
thank you Kevin Park Assist Sarah
correspondence between the number of
incidents and their location in relation
to a sighting and the availability of
the
proving I could have an opinion but
really it's an accurate one I mean at
times yes in fact I think the game's
very much more diverse reviews I mean up
but I think you'll find that those are
responsible are responsible and will
make the effort to get to a dog being
finding reasonable distance you know in
practical terms that I needed obviously
good but we know that they tend to go as
soon as we get out the card and they all
soon as they get to got the beatings
near the entrances then you tend to
capture most of it what you're finding
is but most of you still near entrance
is still and I think before head that I
hope the judges see people not using
most it just seems to happen work in the
hours of darkness or when people are
around so there always be some that do
not wish that concept I'll still think
you'll find that yes the best place you
can put things is luckily Boeing agency
so although logistically you know we
struggle to put them in the middle of
the park majority of fouling tends to be
when don't first gets to the park or
don't you notice relative around so that
they so experience in here use new
experience again have we here in your
opinion do you think that we've got
coverage on this of like the areas where
there's problems or or is there any
areas where you think that it might be a
requirement for some additional beings
in some places I think I overruled it's
okay and so you know and our reluctance
put bins in without there being a need
but certainly where there has been a
call for or a quest to do something on
our space open space then we would do so
yeah I think where we do struggle
slightly and with explain is where
there's a call for bins or toppings
on pavements it's a long drawn-out
process because actually highlights
rather cells it's not our property to
say yes we can put something there and
then say tens take a long time to get
people through our 20 times as far as
it's an optical on there on there I
won't concede to go through that price
it's outrageous but it's early on on
weathers request and open spaces we
should tell you through let me get them
always he takes a bit of time do the
requests come mostly from the general
public or is this through parishes I
would say it comes through district
members or it would come from parishes
as well okay maybe you have friends
groups some sort of solids where you've
been their intelligence you know if
there is AI compellingly than we would
use it for something
thank you very much councillor Stanley
Thank You chairman Marcus do you do you
think that in this past year where we
have had overflow of bins that we should
increase the bins and also perhaps are
much more visual notice for people to
use those bins
well I think if they're overflowing
there obviously people are finding them
I think I think of anything is touching
on a different subject we should
possibly contract management which is
I'll hold my hand up to as well it
sounds it yes I said they just need to
be a much more rigid so I'm you can put
you can put bigger bins in which comes
out called the zoning issues as well and
it's but we can't leave them aspects one
time speaking from personal experience
you know used for these very large bins
in and that's great we try to empty the
things and I've you're finally things
swinging if I to you so heavy so sorry
building these things for us it's about
rather having larger bins or more one go
for you so he's more regular empty and
the soggy geez in as much as penalty
notices that sort of thing more much
more vulgar and so that people is
staring you in the face rather than the
swarm I'm just thinking that the bigger
they are the perhaps we might be able to
increase the the use of them we can look
at that moment certainly going the other
thing we're trying to carry the day and
is just to ensure the bins of a phone
number safety time flying ring um sites
there's been number so we can respond in
quicker most bit removing something
that's been in the pipeline for a while
so I'll just making them announcer games
makes me the other flank being is just
very very quickly on that to compliment
you because when I have hang out before
inside means fun it's been emptied the
following day well the fully Devon I've
gone out but they may have done in the
same day as good well I do clearly they
shouldn't be maybe before they that
you'll be filling the birthplaces I do
attend sir they know place to get your
truth councillor Griffin Oh
Thank You chairman up Marcus took
questions on enforcement is to do with
the public space protection orders do
they have to be authorized by
magistrates
no they don't have no they go through I
remember they've been went through full
council right as you matter or was it
but they they are in consultation with
the Constabulary chief of the constantly
so he has he has cited them before they
they come to serve well they quite easy
to in command
they're relatively sorry I mean the
reason these ones were easier is because
they are a revision of the the the
previous
[Applause]
thank you so you know you know some
saying don't control it so and there was
an expectation that when the doctor
trommel has come to an end
you had this opportunity to almost tweak
them and move them on because in
consultation troubles if you wanted to
bring completely new to the published
smoke detection orders then you would
have to get this consultation to prove
that there was easy to collect evidence
to prove that there was a need for that
order
as these were basically replacing doc
controllable that's always saying is
there was already an established need in
place and we just replacing nervous but
if you want to sound completely separate
you know then you have to sort of wants
to start again and collect evidence fine
thank you Marcus
councillor sees maintenance Thank You
Marcus I think we're all aware that the
highway authority technically when we
sitting right round about six months
plus to approve elimination of the
highway furnitures they called it and if
we're promoting the anything will do
campaign which seems to be a positive
way forward then obviously we've got to
look to where how other things are now
you will recall that a couple of years
ago yes you do the highway authority
without any authority how do you like
that without any authority for District
Council removed and destroyed solve our
business they took more I they didn't
compensate us firstly we did ask for
that I hope you did we ask you to they
could have been some you know two or
three hundred pounds I think it wasting
so they removed them from the bus
shelters and good it probably not just
in our locality probably out that way
but they weren't replaced it sent for
one I believe the councillor edit Mason
pointed out to you was able to prove
that it was there that in that case we
have locations where there were well
there was Highway Authority
four bins we now do not have any bins
there are we able to replace those
hopefully Essex County Council's costs
but seeing in mind they destroyed them
and without any permission to facilitate
this any bin will do we again as you
know it isn't easy with Pouncy to get
things you through at times it is a slow
process I mean I think a process of
taking someone else's property and
destroying it without their permission
a bit strong finish that are we going uh
I don't know what what stand down the
bins we having to put some context is
these were bins that were on bust on
buses and so and when they replace them
they were replaced with modern posts
that could not support those beams but
the main issue is can we replace the
bins if we wanted to because wood or
wood we have to go through the highway
application again because we've we had
permission well I mean I mean they still
got about my life I suspect things were
slightly more relaxed in the past but
there was ever a written permission to
put them on or not something but
certainly now you would need something
because because we could not put them on
those posts again I think we could put
more than posting we may be able to do
so quite easily but the issue is you
have to put them on the pavement so then
we can perhaps an obstacle on the
pavement so
and I said I've made up buddy disease I
wanted is an extra piece of work with
the ovens perhaps what we used to do I
think we read somewhere that you get
don't beans that recycle themselves
biodegrade they are fitted in parsley
into the ground and you go along with
your dog poo take it over the bar itself
yes you men probably put what the
plastic bag in a bin or something but
you do get rid of the dog poo without
our bit to remove it soaked into the
ground biodegrades have a look as well
we have also utopias for Donovan I'm
sorry I couldn't hear everything noise
near me perhaps we should have a noise
reduction policy as well
anything all different they're hearing
sounding very attractive to me until I
started thinking about what I've seen in
the street I've seen dog walkers falling
along
putting their bags into people's bins
and I suddenly thought if he ends up in
the grain bin how pleased would you be
if you ended up in the purple bin you
probably wouldn't worry and if it was in
the green bin in a bag that might bother
you as well so I'm a little concerned
about any bit will do when customarily
there are lots of things available down
the street for people to use you know
that I found all sorts of things that
were mine in my bins in the wrong bins I
was at risk of a general collection
being refused and that kind of bothered
beginning I've noticed that dog walkers
you know had been occasionally I've seen
the birthing babies I'm not suggesting
it was any cancer was that it would be a
sticker or a warning I've been saying
you can put something on the websites
marketing anything would do I think it
needs a little bit more time I've got
occasion where people have identified a
[ __ ] Bulldog flowers
and they can well identify this to you
know that who was the owner of the dog
and they were certainly with them
sometimes with photographs and others by
you know quite long depositions or
stadiums and yet in none of the cases
that we've been able to do anything but
I'm troubled to to know why I didn't
residents I said why why didn't we
there was one if you remember where the
dog was let loose in a children's play
space and defecated all around it do you
remember that one in particular I - I
think I think we did look into that
maanteeeca
and really we could not be certain of
the owner on that cajun so i think so
certainly and our one i should practice
it that the one fund we've done it was
done through different somehow provide
to us so providing i think the witness
thing allows us to move forward we will
do so when certainly you know we don't
have a great deal of enforcing resolves
but what we do have is very enthusiastic
so if there is any evidence that they
feel like so residents can be advised
that if they witness an event of that
sort but it's up to them but they can
take a photograph I'll have to look into
the guys is what we can apologize that's
why I'm asking the question you know I
think it's one of those things we've
done accidentally then the evidence is
quite acceptable I think if they
deliberately go out of their way to
start recording stuff and they're
tripping into sort of areas of
surveillance that that they should be
doing so and that's why I think before I
put anything in that we want to make
sure anything we give in website design
schools I mean just sitting out quite
clearly what is in what is an acceptable
but I think if someone reports we will
take a witness take if someone said I
saw that dog burying a belong to such
and such and they're willing to put
just literally on that I found when I
was doing my researches and to to
counsel was that actually accepted
photographic evidence along with their
witness well that's why I ask the
question because I wondered why we
didn't do that even though their
counsels do I think it's the whole thing
where in the past counselors have been
reluctant to do it and then when one
takes that initial length then they
start realizing that they can go down no
it's true do you know that the other
enforcement is something I think that as
accountability premies undertaking in
the past
and we are still funnier things I just
thought it is in a mummy issue is it a
budget issue is it something that if you
have more money that you can actually do
a better job because this is a
consistent complaint that comes you know
I was gonna say through my door but it
doesn't complain today I think we said
there in certainly of course if you have
more resource and of course you can you
can have more officers to enforce its
just how cost effective that is I think
you know and certainly or to the state
where there is a period of where you're
just going experience as an authority
can enforce advantage in something
that's a bit missus possibly in the past
that we didn't really undertake
enforcement how we should have done but
I think we're doing so now speaking of
experience well we're confident with the
budget coming up hmm do you do you
anticipate making a bid for extra monies
the dog that this stays no do you think
I feel that you would be are asking for
me if you read the report that there's
sort of level of fixed penalty notices
you will be delivering you could be
asking for two or three officers and
you'll be living like a 10x penalty now
she's a year so I think the effects from
doing
just isn't minutes and that that's you
know but that's something for members
that's what brought this you nice if you
know there's you know if that's
something you wish me to go out have a
look at fear that you know other
cost-effective ways of enforcing then it
does touch upon that but my views are
they confront all philosophy and for
some resource of this and get brittle
back thank you it's not just a case from
ourself cost-effectiveness if there's a
health issue here and so that is
concerning I was always surprised that
you said you were hesitant about
photographs the police rigidly assent
dashcam photographs as far as I'm aware
and policeman's advisory this if you're
in the public you could take a
photograph of someone in the public
place you can't take a photograph of
them in a private place but in the
public you could do so and I can't
believe that the police prosecute with a
dashcam and we can't take a photograph
of someone in a park which is the same
level of publicity and openness it's
it's the approach of surveillance is
where surveillance is a general
surveillance and it's acceptable I think
what you got to be insured has probably
gone factory hiding in bushes trying to
catch someone's dog found jumping out of
something that's that being say and so
what we would happily accept its what we
have accepted is we're in CCTV is trying
to cross their garb and then have us
look into the public area and therefore
pick us up something that occurs then we
will use that oh we don't agree I do
survive if it someone's ever looking
they take a photograph that should be
equally acceptable
all right now surfaces Hardy in bushes
I'm not sure that wouldn't be almost a
threatening behavior actually someone
jumping in
I think we're Sony's leave you wouldn't
recommend you look into whether or not
the counselor should be encouraging
mittens it's just clear guidelines if
you can see it's going to click
guidelines on a website that say look
you know we'll take it
you can't actively encourage people to
survive for these sort of things trying
into sort of you know absolutely I think
that was kind of my first movie we can
certainly set up something we've more
robust in terms of reporting yes
counselor good point
thank you Jim - I know you only got one
final May but we regard to fines may be
future fines and then there's the whole
of the money go to the council because I
know in some other areas where these
people are find the money doesn't go to
the council so it does any of the firing
home this money has to go back into the
the enforcement all or cleansing of the
streets say it's ring things for that
matter so yeah I mean we don't have
enough state it goes very quickly back
in let me know what we're going to do
get through so to flight if you anyway
so you know that Navy suddenly very
depleted faith and although I
firefighter disappoint there's only been
one fixed penalty notice I also know as
we discussed in our premed the people
who walk around their dogs do this are
going to be doing it at night when
there's no officers around it's very
very difficult to ever catch those so I
will be investing more staffing just for
this right okay thank you
no other questions
all members of indicated to speak the
recommendation there are two
recommendations the first one
and second destroyed in training issues
on this topic for further consideration
discussion by the committee there would
be any return to the Committee Chairman
maybe that's something that the
committee decides on but we couldn't
India tonight chairman and I suggest
that we would like to further report
back on the issues of India's raised
with mr. homo species raised signage
engines I am relatively new to review
but cannot a report not come back from
the office of its power P actually
taking us because I think there's a lot
of other valuable issues that we should
be reviewing every cat could be
forthcoming in say six months it's
normal for offices to present a report
so anything is
is the first item 3:18 that's now where
it will come off the documents it's not
required there will be an update by the
members family you're having a briefing
on me on this subject at that point yeah
items for a team the fire services
content that was a decision made of the
December executive and aspects went to
the last fall councilman item 1418
register reporter that was issued on the
on the 4th of the 4th of January for a
decision to be made during this month
item 15 18 the mixed recoverable
facilities contract that is going into
the February meeting of
[Applause]
fairly self-explanatory
famille mrs. chairman that the
committee's on target in terms of its
plan the 5th of February meeting has the
treasury management strategy the
consideration party going to thank you
[Applause]